so out of all the Marvel superheroes
that we're going to get their movies the
one I was probably the most concerned
about was Thor because with all the
other superheroes it kind of made sense
they get superpowers or they are based
on technology or they create stuff Thor
was a god
how do you do that and on top of that
his design was always kind of weird he
had a helmet with these weird wings on
it I just remember thinking to myself oh
man this is gonna be the one this is the
one that people are just gonna roll
their eyes at and say sorry Marvel we
can't do this it's just too goofy but
they made the very clever choice of
assigning Kenneth Branagh to direct it
now this is a guy that hasn't really
done any superhero movies and to be fair
he can be kind of hit and miss but he's
got mad Talent and everything he does is
huge and this movie is no exception this
is a gigantic looking film suddenly the
idea of Marvel telling the story of a
god sounds unbelievable look at Thor he
looks amazing look at oten he looks
amazing look at this environment it's
friggin phenomenal which is why it's
really ironic that the least impressive
part of this movie is what Marvel
usually does well the interaction with
the real world yep they just decide to
make this a fish out of water story with
Thor pissing off his father Odin and
Odin banishing him to the world of Earth
taking away his powers he spends his
time befriending a group of scientists
one of them played by Natalie Portman
learning how to be a true humble hero
and figuring out how to get back to stop
his sinister brother Loki from taking
over the throne so on the one hand you
might think the stuff where he goes to
earth is beyond painful and to its
credit it's not is it
good well I don't know if I can say that
but much like Iron Man a lot of the
likeability comes from the charm of the
main actor Chris Hemsworth is a perfect
Thor he can be cocky but like ibly naive
he has a lot of anger but you know deep
down he's a gentle guy and most
importantly of all he adapts I'm so sick
of these movies with a fish out of water
just dazed of
never wants to change anything but this
guy he's a warrior he's fought in
battles so when he throws a cup of
coffee on the ground demanding more and
they tell him that's not how we do
things here he doesn't demand an
explanation or act like a spoiled brat
he says okay this is what makes the
movie work he actually evolves he
actually changes because of this we can
stomach a lot more the traditional stuff
which with that being said it is pretty
traditional the love interest inside
characters on earth are not very
interesting the battle scenes are kind
of standard and yeah was this the best
story you could have done with the idea
of Thor probably not but luckily they do
often come back to the world of the gods
and every time it does it looks amazing
you feel the gigantic size and weight of
this again even though it never loses
track that it's still a comic book in my
opinion maybe one of the greatest
looking comic book movies ever does this
do I make a whole lot of sense not
particularly is it especially engaging
no there's nothing really that new but
the way it's acted and the way it's
shown makes it a lot of fun I wish they
didn't have to do this story where he
travels to earth but it's passable and
anytime it's not on earth it's really
friggin cool we do get a few battles in
this realm and we do feel this
frustration between the brothers Loki
and Thor and though maybe kind of
awkwardly and over time Loki does become
a pretty good villain I guess you could
still look at all this and say it's
still pretty silly but it's just so
epically silly
I love how seriously everybody is taking
this look at the expressions on their
faces look at these visuals this looks
like something out of some grand
mythology so I guess the best way I can
describe it is if you want to see Thor
being Thor
you'll get it it just got away through
some predictable standard stuff but as
that predictable standard stuff goes
it's not as bad as you would think is it
needed probably not but again
remembering the time period this came
out it's not like everybody was just
ready to accept a Thor movie this was
probably the best compromise you can get
at the time the grand stuff is still
grand and it sucks me into its world do
wish there was more of it hell yeah but
for what I got I really enjoyed it
yes I could have used more action and
even more exploration of these worlds
but for what I thought I was gonna get I
was thoroughly impressed not the best by
any means but impressive enough for me